rumination is chatter about the past
worry is chatter about the future but
fundamentally if you find yourself in a
thought loop trying to work through some
kind of problem but not making any
progress that's an indicator that you're
experiencing it
why is it that we have an inner voice at
all can you explain why it is that we
can hear our own thoughts in our heads
yes it's a great question um so i like
to think of the inner voice as a kind of
swiss army knife of the mind that it's a
tool lets us do lots of different things
um things that i well why don't you tell
me how essential you think some of these
things that it allows us to do are
so first of all when i use the term
inner voice what i'm talking about is
our ability to silently use language to
reflect on our lives and and and we
silently talk to ourselves for a variety
of different reasons
one thing that happens to me quite a bit
is i go to the grocery store
and i'm charged by my wife and daughters
with picking up various items inevitably
i get to that grocery store i start
walking down the aisle usually it's the
second or third aisle and i forget what
i'm supposed to get and when that
happens
i start talking to myself i start
thinking what am i supposed to get and
then i list off the items bananas
chocolate cheese
what i'm doing there is i'm using my
inner voice to
keep a nugget of information active in
my head our inner voice is part of what
we call our verbal working memory system
this is a system of the human mind that
is specialized
for allowing us to rehearse information
in a loop
um nowadays people don't really memorize
phone numbers anymore but um we used to
do that did you ever do that when you're
younger yeah i mean i can there's maybe
two or three phone numbers that i can't
remember my home phone number
and my dad's phone number but by the
time that my mum got a mobile phone
i had a phone
so i've never needed to recall hers but
i can remember my dad i can remember my
business partners as well and the reason
i can remember that is because of the
number of times that i heard the answer
machine for him while he was while we
were at university and he was still
asleep or hungover from the night before
so those are the only three numbers that
i can remember but yes
back in the day there were there were
many more that we would memorize but but
but if you were to repeat a phone number
in your head or you meet someone at a
party and you want to not forget their
name you repeat that over and over
that's using your inner voice so most
people rely on their inner voice for
that reason every single day we're using
it um uh in that capacity
we also use our inner voice to do other
things like simulating and planning
stuff before people go on interviews
they often rehearse what they're going
to say in response to different
questions they imagine before i give a
presentation i'll go over the talking
points in my head i'll usually go for a
walk around the neighborhood or the
hotel i'm staying in and i'll go from
the beginning to the end i'll go over
the whole
rigmarole
i'll imagine what a really obnoxious
attendee what question are they going to
ask me
i'll then imagine what i'm going to say
to them
it's usually
not very nice things that i say back um
i'm much nicer
in person than i am in my head we'll get
to that maybe later but so we use our
inner voice to plan right to simulate we
use it to control ourselves when i'm
exercising if i'm in a class with an
instructor or working out one-on-one
i'm smiling to that instructor but in my
head when they're having me do painful
things i am saying all sorts
of not so sweet
things towards them you son of a i'm
counting down come on man you know seven
more reps seven six five that's me using
my inner voice to coach myself along
we can also use our inner voice to
critique ourselves
and then and then finally and i think
this is one of the most
special functions of the inner voice we
use it to make sense of our lives
[ __ ] happens and when that occurs we try
to make sense of that adversity and we
use words to
to create stories that help us
understand what we're going through and
those stories we tell ourselves really
they give shape to our sense of who we
are so your inner voice helps mold your
your identity
so those are four things that our inner
voice does um
i think we're unique in our capacity to
use an inner voice in that way
and i think it is a decided advantage
that we possess
um that that capacity
it seems surprising to me all of that
sounds great
all of those things sound like fantastic
advantages and yet when you talk
about your inner voice or when people
discuss it for the most part they see it
as an adversary they don't see it as a
compadre
that's right well one of my favorite
findings in psychology
can be summed up by the following phrase
it's actually a title of a well-known
paper bad is stronger than good
and and what that means is the bad stuff
tends to stick out a lot more than the
good stuff
and there's a there's a there's an
evolutionary story about why that is the
case we need to be more attuned to
potential threats and losses than than
gains from a survival point of view
um
and i think the same is true for our
inner voice i think we often take it for
granted i think we're not um we don't
always stop and and savor all of the
benefits it provides when it's doing the
things it has evolved to do
but
when that inner voice runs off track
when it morphs into the kind of negative
self-talk or self-dialogue the inner
critic
perks up or um
one of my favorite descriptions i write
about this in my book is dan harris who
describes his inner voice as an [ __ ]
when the inner [ __ ] starts starts you
know yammering away
it really grabs our attention um in ways
that are uncomfortable makes it hard for
us to think and perform undermines our
relationships and health
and and that really motivates us to
to focus on that that nasty inner voice
and and often to try to do something
about it that's interesting something
i've never thought of before the
negativity bias that we have where we
focus on
uh threats more than we do uh potential
advantages
i never thought about that being a
selection mechanism for the things that
go through our own head
oh yeah totally
that's really that's really cool
yeah the negative stuff is is sticking
out there and you know this is a found
as you as you may know this is a
foundational finding the first one of
the first nobel prizes ever awarded
for
a kind of psychological research was was
was given to um
a luminary named danny kahneman
and um it was for this idea of loss
aversion that we're more sensitive to
potential losses in our lives than gains
the same basic finding generalizes to
our inner world much more sensitive to
the bad stuff happening between our ears
than the good stuff it sticks around
long
um longer
how is it that we don't have control
over our own inner voice
my arm doesn't choose
to move on its own
it's not it's not
doing things
against my will it's not continuing to
do the same stuff over and over again
even if i want it to stop
why don't we have control over what the
voice inside of our head says
well i think we i think we can and and
and do and um
but you need to know how to engage um
engage that inner voice um
so
let's talk about
let's break down the the concept of
control and what is under our control
and what isn't i think this is um
often a good place to start so if you
ask me do we have control over the
thoughts that pop into our head while
we're awake while we're asleep
the answer that question is no i don't
think we do
and if we were responsible for all the
thoughts that popped into our head i
think a lot of us would be
imprisoned and in big trouble like i
don't know why when i'm walking down the
street i thought a dark thought pops
into my head at times like
i wish i did
but we don't
so we can't necessarily control the
thoughts that pop into our head but what
we do have a lot of control over is how
we
engage with those thoughts how we
work with them how we manipulate them
how we control them once they're
activated and that's really the the
territory that
i and many other scientists like to play
in right so once a thought is activated
how do you how do you change
its trajectory right so if you find
yourself beginning to go down the rabbit
hole of
worry or rumination or catastrophization
how do you steer that internal dialogue
into a different direction
and the good news here is that there are
lots and lots of things that scientists
have discovered that are useful for
helping people do that
ways of shifting your thinking stepping
back thinking about your circumstances
from a more objective perspective we
call these distancing tools
lots of different ways you can get
distance from your problems to think
more rationally about your search your
circumstances
there are people tools or ways of
engaging with other people that can help
you work through problems in ways that
shift your internal dialogues and and
there are also environmental tools ways
of engaging with our physical spaces
that can be really helpful too
going a little bit further back up the
uh river of
thought
i know that when we're talking about
chatter itself right when it's
manifested and when we've become aware
of it
we can then direct its control but have
you got any idea about where thoughts
come from in the absolute first place
their
pure origin
wow that's a i mean that's a great great
question um
they can certainly be triggered from
external events that um
activate different kinds of associations
from the past
um or sometimes external events really
demand our attention
and you know thoughts thoughts are
often functional in the sense that they
are helping us make sense of the world
and so
if you know you're walking down the
street and you see someone suspicious
15 a feet ahead of you you're going to
have a certain set of thoughts activated
that are designed to help you deal with
that circumstance in that particular
instance you'll also experience an
emotional response in all likelihood
that is functional a negative response
right
threat detected and you're going to be
alerted for dealing with it
we can also though
activate thoughts
through thinking and this is one of the
ways in which chatter really sinks us
lots of people think for example that
stress kills right i mean this is like a
meme out there
avoid stress
that's not actually true
as i like to point out
you wouldn't want to live life without
being able to experience a stress
response
the fact that you have a system a
coordinated system in your body
that quickly prepares you to respond to
threats in your environment to either
approach or avoid them
super useful system to have
what makes stress truly toxic from a
health point of view
is when your stress response goes up and
then remains chronically activated over
time
it's that chronic activation of stress
that exerts a wear and tear in your body
that leads to things like cardiovascular
disease and inflammation and all sorts
of
boogeyman-like physical disorders
and
what accounts for that elevated chronic
stress response is chatter it is
thinking because we are capable of
re-simulating the things that are
worrying us or bothering us and when we
do
that activates related thoughts and um a
biological reaction as well
so so our thoughts can come from lots of
different places including places that
we're not certain of and i think it's
important to share that with folks too
that you know the human mind is one of
the most mysterious
um
physical structures that
are that is out there and we are trying
to improve our understanding i think
we've made a lot of
progress in shedding light on how the
human mind works but like there is a lot
a lot that we still don't know well sam
harris says if it wasn't for the fact
that we are conscious
we would have no idea that consciousness
exists out there in the universe right
aside from the fact that we're able to
experience it firsthand there is
absolutely no um evidence that shows
that it's something that's occurring and
i it's interesting what you talk about
the fact that you end up with kind of
like a thought cascade so a thought can
trigger a thought through an association
even if you don't know that those two
things are associated
and then from there our ability to
ruminate perpetuates that we are the
architects of our own sort of cyclical
thinking over and over and over again
when it comes to verbalizing thought one
of the things
that i realized was that
given the fact that our inner voice uses
words
does that mean that different languages
can engender different thought patterns
i think german is one of those one of
those languages where they have tons and
tons of words for things that we don't
perhaps in the west like shard and freud
and things like that
that that kind of enables a different
type of thought almost
yeah well you know there's um lots of
interesting connections between um
language and our experience of emotions
and it is absolutely true that certain
cultures have um words to describe
emotional responses that we don't have
in in the united states
which um raises questions about the
universality of certain kinds of
emotional experiences and the degree to
which
emotions are
emotions reflect these
innate natural kinds of phenomena as
opposed to more constructed
experiences that are
our culture helps us you know make sense
of
um
so in terms of the inner voice and
language and foreign languages or
different languages some of the the most
relevant work here that i that i really
love this never made it into my book
that um
it got it got
what's the expression on the chopping
room floor
um
but it's really cool science it involves
asking the question
how does talking to yourself about an
emotional experience in a foreign
language
change your the way you talk to yourself
how does it change your emotional
experience and what that research shows
is that
when we think about our emotional
circumstances in a second language
we're able to think about them in a more
objective way
because
our primary languages are the languages
in which we first learn about emotion
experience emotion
our second that are the second languages
that we learn are a bit of they're a
little bit more clinical and abstract
if you ever tried do you speak more than
one language no no i'm in guatemala and
i've i've pulled every essence of
spanish that i can out of the half gcse
i did nearly 20 years ago in school and
uh it's it's been
terrible it's been tough okay well
anyone who's listening i would encourage
them to to try this exercise
try cursing first in in your primary
language and then try
engaging in the same curse words in your
second language curse words don't have
nearly the same sting they're kind of
funny sometimes to even utter them in a
second language as compared to the first
because they don't have the same
associations i mean if you want to get
back to this idea of associations
emotional memories
are encoded in our primary language
so your primary language is is really
the terrain of very rich emotion
and you can actually leverage this
phenomenon to your betterment if you're
trying to work through a problem or some
chatter try to think it through in your
second language and um research suggests
that you might be a little bit less
emotional more rational in how you do so
yeah it's interesting the the
effortfulness of having to think about
what it is that you mean in a language
that isn't your first language is
probably going to provide some
distancing which i know we'll probably
get onto another thing that i considered
is that as you learn
new or more words in in your primary
language you're recreating the capacity
of your inner monologue right you're
actually enabling different ways for you
to understand things and i suppose that
you could then roll that forward to
concepts you learn a new concept like
availability bias or handles razer or
you learn about some sort of
psychological trait that you may have or
something like that
and it makes me think about
what what constitutes us what
constitutes me as a person if i can
learn a new word
and then use it
and
prior to not having that word i was
still me and having had this word i'm
still me but i consider the thoughts
that are in my head to somehow be a part
of me or a representation of me or
something like that what does it mean to
add new words in what does it mean that
i can kind of augment myself
with new
language all of that together seems like
a bit of a messy situation well
it's it's a beautiful mess i would say
and at least in the way i think about it
because um
the mind is is very flexible and on our
ability to make sense of our experiences
in this world i mean look we can we can
create stories
to make sense of almost anything right
one of my a classic study in psychology
and i've ever heard of um
the the
cognitive dissonance discovery with the
ufos and things like that i've ever
heard this story it's a great story so
um
leon festinger and his students stanley
schachter two two um
major players in social psychology
basically they wanted to understand what
happens if people believe in something
really really strongly
and are then presented with evidence
that
there's no
getting around it the evidence clearly
says you are wrong in this belief
another question is a simple one when
you're presented with evidence that
contradicts your beliefs what do you do
do you update your beliefs
or do you come up with some creative
rationalization
to allow yourself to maintain these
beliefs
and their prediction was a controversial
one at the time which is they said
actually when you're presented with
undeniable evidence that you're wrong
that's going to be such a threat to your
sense of who you are that you're going
to figure out a way of
bending your uh your your mind to make
sense of this new circumstance and i
think that that's one response i have to
your your question about the messiness
of the mind
one thing that keeps that messiness in
check is that we are motivated to be
consistent in how we think about
ourselves and the world around us and so
yeah we can learn new concepts and ways
of thinking about things but
usually we're not going to take those
ideas
and do a total 180
in terms of how we think about who we
are and present ourselves to the world
we are going to maintain some
consistency anyway get back to the
detour of the
of that study i was telling you about
so how does shakhtar and festinger test
this idea about whether we
take in the new evidence update our
ideas or not
they infiltrate a cult
these are these are like professors and
graduate students they infiltrate a cult
in minnesota that believes
in um an alien race that has been
visiting the planet for a while to see
what's going on and this alien race has
determined that there's going to be this
doomsday event on this particular day
and
when this happens
if everyone in the cult get comes to
this certain place they'll be saved go
on the spaceships and go to the planet i
think it was clarion which is a little
funny because there is a a chain of
hotels here in the united states that is
called the clarion hotel it's hard for
me to take it seriously anyway they've
infiltrated the cult and they're there
on the day when the aliens are supposed
to come
and guess what happened chris no aliens
no aliens
um
i should say by the way for anyone's
listening i'm open to the idea of there
being
aliens that run a successful chain of
hotels in america yes exactly exactly
exactly just not the ones that take this
shape um so they don't come and um and
then they
what does that what do the cult members
do well turns out
they just make excuses for this and that
well you know it didn't happen but it's
going to happen three months from now
they make all their they're re-writing
this internal narrative that has been
guiding them for all of this time
leading them to invest money in
preparations for the migration and so
forth and so on um so this observation
was really the the way we stumbled on
this idea of cognitive dissonance this
idea that
um
we really don't like
to
um
admit we're wrong and and and really
update
you know ideas even when we're presented
with information that contradicts them
isn't the
part of the explanation for how
uh consciousness works or how identity
works the fact that we commit ourselves
to those positions is because
ancestrally it would have made a lot of
sense for us to try and be someone that
looks
reliable
um
uh consistent
like they have control over their sort
of conscious processes and what they're
going to do if we were fully verbalizing
all of the things that go through our
heads or if it was that we weren't
actually as committed to the personality
that we have it would be chaos because
the person that was a farmer yesterday
has woken up and doesn't want to be a
farmer today he wants to be something
else he wants to be a hunter you go no
no no you're supposed to be that person
and i remember reading about how
it was
supposedly adaptive for people to stick
to their guns in that sort of a way
because it makes their behavior more
predictable which actually can cause a
tribe to be it cohesive together in a
more efficient way because there's not
constantly tons of flux as people change
from one type of person to another
yeah i mean that's a that's a very
popular evolutionary theory and it's one
that makes a lot of sense evolutionary
theories are always hard to completely
everything's just so right yeah it's
hard right because you can't go back in
time necessarily and do this but um
but it's but it's a theory that does
have some support behind it and it makes
good sense what we do know is that
human beings we are highly motivated
to
have a sense of order and control we
like certainty we like to know that the
world is predictable because when the
world is predictable it's easier for us
to navigate and that generalizes to our
social relationships as well right we
want to know that people are dependable
and so forth and so on and so um so i
think that does make sense and and look
the things happening in our mind when
we're pinballing back and forth
um
that isn't always a very controlled
atmosphere inside
and you know it's interesting in the age
of of transparency i think people often
you could push it to an extreme so i
don't know everything you're thinking in
fact some social media applications
actually ask you to share what is on
your mind that's the prompt or was the
last time i checked on um
on facebook or meta or whatever it's
called
not telling people what i'm thinking all
the time
there's a little bit of filtering that
i'm going to do
before i share it with someone else and
i think that filtering is serves a
really useful function
can you imagine if we were to go into
some minority report world
in the future where we were actually
able to read people's thoughts first off
i'm pretty sure that a lot of the people
who see themselves as the most virtuous
would find themselves
pretty close to the bottom of the pile
um
and also you're right
it's strange the fact that we have this
odd cascade of thoughts which can be
triggered by thoughts and perpetuated by
thoughts
means that we end up in um
oh what was that film there was a film
that came out where everyone's in a
monologue was verbalized outside of
their heads
the jim carrey film was that the one no
sunshine of the spotless no no this one
came out the last year or the year
before it's uh
with violet there's a there was one on
the inner voice
yeah i think so it's about a dystopian
future world where technology's crashed
a little bit it was within the last two
years this thing's come out and they
have uh what do they call it
i think they might call it the voice or
the whisper or something like that and
you can hear what everybody says outside
of their heads no really what happens um
well it's a nightmare obviously because
no one can hide things and um the
chieftain one of the this sort of
totalitarian guy that looks after one of
the one of the big tribes he doesn't
have a voice he's been able to control
it and then there's this kid who is the
protagonist and he really struggles he's
trying to talk to girls and he's always
saying how cute she looks and stuff like
that and it just weirds everybody out
and then over time the the journey is
him sounding sounds like my childhood
yeah maybe dude you should watch it it's
it's right appeals
what's
remember i'll send it to you afterwards
people are screaming it into their
headphones at the moment um
what
how does age
and gender influence chatter are there
correlations there
so we know that um chatter tends to be
higher among women than men um
there are two caveats i always like to
provide after
describing that statistic um number one
there are many things that men many
problems of the mind or problems of
living that men score higher on than
women so it all averages out if you look
at the full terrain
but second many of the tools that exist
for managing chatter work equally well
for men and for women
um with age you know you could begin to
see signs of so the the earliest study i
was able to find that had some trace of
inner voice-ness occurring among kids
was around 18 months of age
that's probably not the earliest that it
occurs but
methodologically it's hard to do this
kind of research when you get much
younger
but we see chatter the harmful version
of the inner voice beginning to occur
pretty pretty early on and you know
young school-aged kids
start to experience worry and rumination
and it oscillates it changes over the
lifespan
it's also important to know that
just because you know it it's easy to to
bucket people into hey you're a worry or
you're a chatter and you're not
in fact there are domains of chatter
some people are
really good about not experiencing
chatter at all when it comes to
relationships when it comes to the
to their work life chatter chatter
chatter and vice versa so there is a
profile that characterizes people
what are your chatter triggers let me
ask you god dude anything i i really do
struggle to um
to not think
i've done a lot of mindfulness you know
five years or something over a thousand
sessions of meditation and it's
definitely made me
be more aware and more intentional
so my ability to step in to
see hear or feel
whatever it is that's arisen in in the
mind and then to let it go
is
it feels like a superpower it genuinely
feels like a superpower especially
compared to the person that i was half a
decade ago um but i find it very
difficult to not notice things so as as
i'm walking through a hotel i'll notice
that a woman has got one sock higher
than the other and i'll have to think
about why why she got one soccer
another thing to do with socks it's not
always to do with feet i went to a party
a couple of months ago in in austin uh
and
people came into this house this very
nice house where the party was uh and
they were told to take their shoes off
at the door and about 50 of people took
their shoes off and about 50 of people
took their shoes and their socks off and
i was obsessed the rest of the party
almost all i could think about was like
what bound together to sock people and
what bound together the bare feet people
and what was it about
why was i one of the non-sock people and
what that was so
you're just you're just you're just a a
lay psychologist chris you just got to
come to our phd program here fantastic
i'll get you trained up i knew that that
was the case and then we can do some
foot analysis we can find out what the
uh inner monologue of people that don't
wear socks when they go to a party is so
great talking about that
obviously we can have different sorts of
projections inside of our mind right we
can project visual images
we can also have a hear
sensation so that verbalizing in a
verbalizing and then we can have
a feel so sort of emotions i guess that
are a little bit more ephemeral and
probably somewhere between the two
is it possible to quieten the mind or is
it only possible to change what it's
saying
um
well i think once you i think they're
they're often related so um
when you're struggling with either
imagery um that is aversive and
promoting chatter or a nasty internal
dialogue
changing the the trajectory of the that
dialogue or imagery is often linked with
quieting the mind and you know once you
once you address the negativity it
becomes easier than to just move into
into a kind of autopilot mode now i do
think it's really interesting i'd love
your take on this as someone who has
experience with meditation mindfulness
which which i do as well and i gen
um genuinely
i was about to say generally friday
afternoon and what you know it's that
time of the day
i genuinely value mindfulness meditation
i've been doing it on and off since i
was five years old believe it or not
but i do think that it is one tool among
many that we can use to manage our minds
and further i think oftentimes the way
that some of the philosophical ideas
that
really have given rise to mindfulness
some of those the way those ideas are
promoted
actually
distort the original intent and what i
mean by that is this we often hear that
the goal should be a quiet mind the goal
should be
to be in the now to be in the moment to
not being to dip into the future or past
and actually
i think that that is not a realistic
goal nor one that
we should all strive for to be in the
moment at all times and what i mean by
that is
the human mind is a time traveler we
evolve the capacity to travel in time in
our mind
and this this is a kind of superpower i
think you use that term but
me being able to think back to the last
conversation i had what went right what
went wrong right that's a source of
self-improvement me being able to think
about the vacation i recently went on my
with my family and savor that when i'm
not having a great day that's a huge
source of resilience me being able to
think about the next six months and what
i want to accomplish and the
difficulties i may have on the horizon
how i'm going to deal with them that's
essential to my ability to be productive
and successful so traveling in time in
our mind when i go for a walk in the
park letting my mind go to these
different places i think this is part of
the reason to degree that i've had any
success in this world it's that capacity
that plays an outsized role in
predicting that kind of success
sometimes of course the mental time
travel machine breaks down and we get
stuck in the past or the future
which is essentially chatter
one approach there is to is to refocus
momentarily on the present
but that's only one thing you might want
to do in that instance i think we don't
always want to be in the present so i'm
curious what you have to say you know
what's your take on do you think we
should always be striving to be in the
moment
it's a difficult question because
obviously it's not super adaptive
for that to be the case it wouldn't do
for us to only ever be in the moment
because we would never learn from things
that we did in the past and we would
never be able to anticipate challenges
that were going to come in in the future
um
it's interesting because
the sort of bro science mindfulness
solution to everything is to just come
back to the present moment um
and yet i'm going to guess that if you
dig into the psychological research
that's not necessarily always the
best solution
well i i think the
you know i'm i'm a fan of there not
being any one-size-fits-all solutions i
think we've evolved the capacity to
utilize you know probably close to three
dozen different tools at least in
counting right now for managing our
chatter for a reason different people
different situations require different
kinds of tools and so
i think we get in trouble potentially by
giving people what i think is an
unattainable goal
it's not possible to always be in the
moment i mean have you come across
anyone who's always in the moment no
i've come across people that say that
they're always in the moment but i i
don't believe that they are yeah i think
you know just
knowing about how the mind works it's it
we evolved to not be in the moment and
we've evolved for a reason so um so it's
it's it's setting people up to
have an unattainable goal that is also
not something that is functional and so
i'd i'd rather i'd love to shift the
conversation to get us talking about
being in the moment as one kind of tool
we use to manage our chatter but hey
there's a whole big toolbox out there of
other skills that we we can also
activate
is it true that some people don't have
an inner monologue
no
i thought so
i thought that was [ __ ] i i get this
question a lot and and um because every
every few months someone usually writes
on the internet that they don't have an
inner voice
so this is where i think it's really
important to be clear about what we mean
when we use the phrase inner voice and
when i use that phrase i'm talking about
silently using language and as i
mentioned earlier there are many
many
contexts in which we call upon that tool
ranging from
reminding ourselves of what's on our
grocery list and memorizing a phone
number to having a full-blown
back-and-forth dialogue with ourselves
are there some people who may only
only resort to that inner voice to
keep in mind what they have to buy in
the grocery store and don't ever talk to
themselves sure i think we lean on these
different functions for to different
degrees
but in terms of do we have it do we all
have an inner voice
yes
that working memory system that i
mentioned before that is a basic feature
of the human mind all well-functioning
human minds have it
there must be people that you've come
across in your research who've had some
sort of brain trauma
or
some sort of genetic
uh
dysformation deformity that's caused
them to not have it though
yes um
those are no more no longer
well-functioning minds and and they're
fascinating um there's one story i'm
particularly fond of a woman who
suffered a stroke
that was localized in the left
hemisphere of her brain
a vein popped right around
the parts of her brain or parts of her
brain that were involved in speech
production and so she
temporarily lost the ability
not only talk to other people but also
to use words to talk to herself
and what's fascinating about her story
is this is a woman who was very well
accomplished she was a harvard
neuroanatomist
and
she would often before the stroke
complain about all the chatter she was
experiencing she described it as
tremendously debilitating she wished she
wished she could just get rid of her
voice well the wish unfortunately came
true
but what's astounding to me about her
story um is
she she ended up describing her
experience in a book um when you when
asked how did she feel after
after she could no longer talk to other
people herself
the word she described it as euphoric
she described herself as going to la la
land
so you've just had someone who has had a
massive stroke can't communicate anymore
to other people herself and she's
blissfully happy why
because although words escaped her so
did all of the chatter and she found
that incredibly liberating right no more
obnoxious roommate in her head chirping
away all the time leaving her to
self-guess herself and focus on you know
the people who wore socks versus didn't
at the party
and and so she found that really
liberating um now she goes on to say
that it actually was an impairment
because
although it was really nice to not have
the chatter for a while
she she couldn't do basic things like
keep information active in her head or
make sense of what was happening to her
in the world and so um so her experience
is always a great reminder to me of
how the goal shouldn't be to silence the
inner voice it should be to figure out
how to how to manage it more effectively
i like that are you familiar with ian
mcgill work mastering his emissary and
the matter with things
no tell me more so he the thing that
came up for me there was to do with the
strokes and he mentioned how he's a
philosopher and a neuroscientist
and he looked at strokes that affect the
left hemisphere and strokes that affect
the right hemisphere he said that for a
long time uh
doctors had thought that strokes
affecting the right hemisphere were um
preferable because you still retain
speech
language all that stuff so communication
is super easy but
what you don't retain is empathy or the
ability to understand why other people
aren't happy with the things that you're
doing or motivation and intention and
stuff like that and
it seems now that given the choice if
you were to pick the two it seems
significantly easier to retrain language
and to retrain forms of communication
with a left hemisphere stroke than it is
for the people who are around the person
that's had the stroke to overcome
the
pretty difficult to deal with total lack
of empathy total lack of emotion you
lose more of who you are as a person and
that into those interpersonal skills
bizarrely when you can't speak
you are in a better position than when
you can't sort of feel feelings anymore
uh i just thought that was that was a
really interesting way to look at things
that
speech is less central to
our personhoods than
the the the emotions that drive that
speech
well i mean it's a fascinating question
and it sounds like having to choose
between the lesser of two evils if i
have my choice i'll choose neither um
but but you know i
i mean empathy for example and the
ability to relate to others i mean the
some have described that as a social
glue that binds
our species together and when it goes
away um
you know you don't always need a stroke
in the right hemisphere to get a lack of
empathy there are some people who for
reasons we're still trying to figure out
don't have it
we call them
sociopaths and
things don't always work out very well
for them
should people speak to themselves in the
third person if they want to motivate
themselves
absolutely provided they don't do it
while walking down the streets of london
without air pods in their ears
so
um
you know
one one thing that we know from lots of
research is that people are much better
at giving advice to others than they are
giving advice to themselves when they're
struggling with something really
emotional i find it striking that
whenever i give a presentation on this
work and i ask people hey have you ever
been in a situation where a friend or a
loved one comes to you with a problem
they're ruminating about
they don't know what to do they present
the situation to you and it's relatively
easy for you to coach them through the
situation has ever happened every single
on the hand in the audience goes up
there's actually a name for this
phenomenon we call solomon's paradox
named after the bible's king solomon
who as you probably know was world
renown
for being a sage for being a wise leader
but if you dig into his personal history
turns out
he made a rash of terrible decisions
that ultimately led to his demise as as
a leader
he got caught up in
not only love triangles but love
octagons and and got into you know a
huge hot mess
so so there's this finding right we can
coach other people better than we can
coach ourselves
what we've learned over the years is
that
what we call distant self talk trying to
coach yourself through a problem using
your name or the second person pronoun
you so come on ethan you can do this
that's a tool that plays off this
mechanism
because if you think about when do we
use names or words like you we use names
and second person pronouns and we think
about and refer to other people so the
links in the mind between using a word
like you and thinking about someone else
is super strong
so when you use that word to refer to
yourself
it's essentially turning on the the
brain machinery for thinking about
others
and that that that alters our
perspective it puts us in a position to
start giving ourselves much much wiser
advice so this is actually the first
thing that i personally do if i detect
some chatter bright come on ethan
how are you going to manage a situation
what are you going to do
um
and and it often it often does make a
difference and there's a lot of science
to back that up have you ever done it
yeah i have i mean you know one of
jordan peterson's rules is treat
yourself like you are someone you are
responsible for helping and uh i wrote a
newsletter about that and probably two
years ago now that said exactly what you
went through like how many times has
someone come to you
with a problem and you've given them
this really sort of wonderful blend of
sympathy
with firmness with support where you
just it's this gorgeous blend and you
sort of really sort of get them on their
way
and a lot of the time that's a situation
that you yourself could do with that
same advice for that's exactly right
and you'll you'll kick yourself in the
dick as you push yourself out the door
your equivalent is so much more ugly
that's right i mean we say things to
ourselves
that we would never
dare say to um a friend let alone a
worst enemy
and and this is where distant self-talk
i think really helps it it greases the
wheels for providing that kind of
friend oriented advice
giving that to ourself it's leveraging
the structure of language to put us in a
position where we start doing that
relatively effortlessly and
automatically so we don't have to stop
and think hey what would i tell
matthew in this situation that's right
ethan here's what you're going to do it
just flips a switch and we've actually
done neuroscience studies on this in one
study we find that the emotional
regulatory benefits of this tool kicks
in
um in about a second actually um
this was really really quick i mean just
try doing it yourself i
you know i chris like
it's a visceral feeling that many people
have
um
you know this this tool has been around
for quite a while um i think it often
gets ridiculed because we see it pop up
in television sitcoms where people are
being made fun of for talking themselves
out loud about themselves
but um julius caesar henry adams
um didn't julius caesar write a whole
book in yeah he wrote a whole book in
the third place
a book about a difficult military
exploit um henry adams wrote his
autobiography in the third person
um
malawia yusofsi you know the youngest
person ever win the nobel's peace prize
when um jon stewart
a host of a television show here in the
states or previously was when he had her
on the show to talk to her about
hey
what was going through her head when she
discovered that the taliban were
plotting to kill her
she she does this wonderful
she tells us wonderful i mean terrible
but also the way she tells it is
wonderful story about discovering the
the news that the taliban were coming to
get her and then the moment where she
she simulates what's gonna happen when
they get to the front door she switches
into coaching herself using her own name
well i used to say to myself what would
you do malala if they come and get you
well then i would reply just take a shoe
and hit him so she's she's contemplating
this tremendously stressful circumstance
and she switches into using her name to
coach herself through it
there's something we some people stumble
on this tool
and i think the value associated with
knowing about the science surrounding is
now now you and anyone who's listening
can just be more deliberate in how they
incorporate it into their lives
matt fraser
world crossfit champion won the crossfit
games five times most dominant athlete
ever in its history
i i saw an interview with him and he
said that he always refers to himself in
the third person um and you know
a lot of the time when we're doing stuff
that we require sort of acute motivation
for i have three more reps to go i have
two more reps to go i have one more rep
to go
um or you're running it's uh memorial
day mirth is a workout that often gets
done and um people will need that
because it's a one mile run followed by
a
hell of sort of body weight exercises
and then another one mile run so as
you're going through this run with a
weighted vest and you'll just get to the
next lamp post for him it would be right
matt just get to the next lamppost just
get to the next lamppost um it is
bizarre that
we have this
it's not a negativity bias although it
is negative
language
it's like a a callousness
bias or a lack of empathy bias that we
have toward ourselves have you got any
idea why that is
um why do we say things to ourselves
that we would never say to someone else
you know it's a great question well we
don't have to stand on ceremony with
ourselves um there are lots of norms i
mean this is one
hypothesis um idea bro signs it ethan
come on yeah okay
um
you know
there are social norms that dictate how
we speak to other people and those norms
are are taught to us at a very very
young age right so we don't act in ugly
ways
we don't necessarily even always speak
the
absolute truth about how we feel about
someone else um all the time sometimes
we kind of dress it up to to
to
ease the the the blow or the burden that
what we're going to say is going to have
on someone
we don't have those
norms for talking about ourselves i mean
there's an interesting question here
can you change the norms
associated with how you talk to yourself
um now that's a really interesting
question that i would love to see some
research address like
can you teach people to be kinder and
more constructive to themselves
chronically over time not just to be
corrective about it when you find
yourself being nasty to remember to
switch into this more compassionate mode
but can you actually train that
it's like self-personal
re-socialization
yeah yeah it's really fast i mean i
haven't ever really thought about i
think it's a really fascinating question
now there is of course something to be
said about being
honest with ourself as well
um
so
the you know when you describe for
example what you wrote in your
newsletter about that blend of
compassionate but also
honest and stern feedback
that's not typically the way that people
often describe
certain types of self-compassion
self-compassion is often described as
more
genuinely accepting of of yourself as a
human being and and it's great great
data associated with it but i do think
there is a case for the the tough coach
so to speak
right
the
the drill sergeant that's gonna also
when necessary be straight with you
about something that isn't working out
and there's a question of how to balance
that isn't it the case that anything
that you are exposed to a lot you become
desensitized to right like when
everything's racist nothing's racist but
when everything that you do sucks
nothing that you do so it's you need to
balance that you know if we have this
super negative mindset and you're never
happy with any of the outcomes or the
outputs that you've done it's very very
difficult for you to then
where do you go from there well it
doesn't always happen the the the the
habituation i think is what you were
saying you just kind of get you know if
you if you seen once if you see a snake
a hundred times it's not like the first
time in fact though
um sometimes where we get stuck is we
don't actually habituate we we remain
sensitive to the negative stuff
and and that's in part i think where
people get in trouble right it's because
we are so adept at finding new ways
to freak ourselves out
really really good at it right like
you'd think chris how many times have
you worried or ruminated about something
in your life and learned that that
outcome didn't happen oh it's 99
of the time
yet you've continued to do it and that
speaks and it continues to trigger me
and it continues to trigger exactly that
speaks to the flexibility
of the mind and our ability to just keep
on making ourselves resilient against
learning yes
impressively resilient against learning
and that's where the ability to take
that step back
and look at what we're going through
from a different point of view can be
really really helpful right because we
just go down these scripts
of churning stuff over and over and over
again
not productive but when you step back
and look at the bigger picture think
about it like you know you tell someone
else or
you know
write a story or talk to someone who can
help you put in perspective those are
different ways of attacking a problem
that can change your trajectory
that's a third third-person language
distancing
is there anything else to add on to that
to augment with that is there anything
we haven't said so that people can use
that strategy
yeah there are lots let me give you a
rapid fire um so
there's no one distancing strategy that
exists turns out there are many many
different ways of
stepping back
looking at the bigger picture and
thinking about ourselves from a less
immersed more detached point of view
another common distancing strategy that
has a lot of science behind it i use it
myself is called temporal distancing
distancing through time so this is a
tool i use
every time i wake up in the middle of
the night with some chatter it happens
every four to six weeks it's like i'm
wide awake oh my god how is that gonna
what am i gonna do
you know three seconds later i'm
visualizing myself visualizing myself
either in jail or the hospital
it's not good
temporal distancing think about how
you're going to feel about whatever
you're struggling with the next day or
the next week or six months from now
what we have what we all know from just
living life is that lots of emotional
experiences they come but they
eventually go they subside but when you
are in the midst of of experiencing
chatter we lose sight of that so
reminding yourself of the fact that hey
i'm gonna feel better about this in the
morning i'm gonna be able to manage this
in the morning
that that does something really powerful
for a chatter-prone mind and it
highlights
the instability of what we're going
through it's saying hey there is there
is hope
and that that takes the edge off in a
way that can be quite quite helpful
super simple thing to do i mean this is
another thing that excites me so much
about a lot of the tools i talk about
there a lot of complex science went into
their identification and validation but
they're easy to implement and and the
reason that i like that is
the easier things are to do
the more likely people are going to be
to do them so i have made a plan in my
head if i wake up at 2 a.m then i'm
going to use temporal distancing i've
rehearsed that plan and now it's on
autopilot i do it instantly and i don't
freak out as a result so that's another
distancing strategy another one that
plays on the visual modality is
if you're seeing a scene if you're
replaying a um a scene over and over in
your head
uh adopt a fly in the wall perspective
see yourself in the event like you're
looking at someone else and try to make
sense of why that person you're looking
why are they acting the way they are
that's another distancing tool
um journaling that that can also help
that also activates distance talking to
other people can be really helpful if
you choose the right people to talk to
someone who's adept at not only
connecting with you empathically using
you know hopefully not the stroke
victims you were referring to before
um but then also people who don't just
get you to rehash what you're going
through but people who then
help you broaden your perspective right
a lot of us think that the way to give
good support to get good support and
give it is to just vent our emotions
what we know about venting is venting
venting can be really good for
strengthening the friendship on
relational bonds between people it's
good to know that you know chris we're
connected now and you're here for me but
if all i do is vent to you about
something i leave that conversation i
feel good about our relationship but i'm
just as upset as i was when i started
talking how do you define venting
just unloading rehearsing what happened
to you and what what you felt without
trying to shift towards some cognitive
change what some way of making sense of
the experience what's the step to go
from then someone catches themselves
venting what do they do
so what if you're let's say you're in
the role of being my chatter advisor my
coach what you want to do is you want to
you want to learn about what i'm going
through
let's back up a second
people have two needs that they're
trying to fulfill when they go to
someone else for support they have
social emotional needs they want to feel
validated and connected with someone
else but they also have cognitive needs
they need to make sense of
this problem they're dealing with in a
way that lets them move on with their
lives and ideally the person you're
talking to helps address both of those
needs how do they do that
first thing you do is you genuinely
empathically
learn about what happened to the other
person so chris tell me what happened
with that last podcast guest really they
said that sounds terrible how did you
fee you know learn a little bit about it
and then when you sense that the time is
right
then you want to start shifting the
conversation to
move towards solutions and alternative
ways of thinking so
well you've dealt with that kind of
guess before chris how have you dealt
with it in the past what have you done
or i've been in that situation here's
what i've done or well you know what big
picture this is one guesstimates so lots
of different ways you can broaden the
person's perspective
now there is an art to doing this well
and what i mean by that is depending on
the person you're talking to and what
they're dealing with some people will
need to spend more time
sharing their emotions before they're
ready to transition
into having their perspective being
broad so you you wanna feel that out so
if my wife comes to me with some chat or
she wants to talk about i'll stop i'll
listen
and then i'll ask her hey i totally get
it i have a thought can i share it
sometimes she'll say no keep listening
other times like please tell me so so
that's the art of being a good chatter
advisor
i like the fact that
you have asked the question um
what kind of what do you want from me at
this stage like are you done
feeling validated by me hearing what you
have to say or do you want a solution i
had a psychotherapist on the show last
year adam lane smith and he was talking
about the fact that um men and women
deal with their problems in two
completely different languages that
women he said on average appear to want
to feel like they have been heard like
they've been validated like their
emotions are understood
and what men are trying to do from the
second that this begins is what's the
problem how can i fix it like men are
interested in things women are
interested in people and the reverse
happens as well you mentioned about how
male and female depression gets treated
too that
female depression is treated by making
them feel safe like they belong like
they are loved and
he's like men don't necessarily want
that they want to feel like they have a
purpose and the ability to achieve it
well you know i i would say that there
is some variability um so there is some
research which shows that so both of
these needs these social and cognitive
needs
these are these are needs that both men
and women possess
but um but there is you know so so
actually some of this research is this
was groundbreaking research done by a
dutch psychologist
no
a belgium psychologist i'm in big
trouble now um
we'll scrap that a belgium psychologist
named bernard remay and
he actually tackled this question of
is it the case that women just want the
emotional stuff and then the cognitive
and in fact he found there's much more
similarity than than differences so i
think there's certainly those archetypes
that exist
but i can tell you i've got i've got you
know buddies call me all the time men
and they often want to vent a little bit
and i have to remind them all right
venting you ready for
the cognitive stuff or you want to keep
and so so i think there's a lot of
variability there i think you're right
but um
so other people can be a remarkable tool
but i think a lot of us
get it wrong um this is myself included
before i knew about this work i think a
lot of us think
the way to help is to just do one or the
other just listen or just advise in fact
it's a blend but you asked me about
other distancing tools let me tell you
about one more
it comes from the environment i think
it's super cool
it involves experiencing the emotion of
awe which is an emotion we experience
when we're in the presence of something
vast and indescribable and you can get
this ah experience from lots of places
like
some people get it from um
exercise exercising outside or like
going for a walk in the park
some people get it from imagining their
you know witnessing their kids doing
some amazing thing
i get it from um
well i get it from many places but the
last big one for me was watching the
spaceship land on mars like just
contemplating back to aliens right like
my god we figured out how to travel
between planets like
that's amazing and so what happens to
your chatter when you experience awe
is something equally remarkable
all leads to something called a
shrinking of the self
we feel smaller when we're contemplating
something vast and indescribable and
when we feel smaller so does our chatter
so to make that concrete
you know i could have i wrote an email
earlier today that might have been
interpreted the wrong way and i could be
lost in that thought loop about oh my
god what if they thought about this
email or i could be thinking about the
fact that there are people who figured
out how to land a spa an suv sized
vehicle on another planet and then have
a live stream back to us like come on
man put your problems in perspective and
i did a little distant self-talk there
just to slip it in as well very nice i
like that is there any science behind
positive affirmations
there's a lot of science between behind
positive affirmations and it turns out
that it is um
it's complicated um would you like to
say [ __ ] no no no no no okay no no
self affirmations can be can be useful
in certain contexts but but they're not
a panacea um
and so they're not going to
be you know i i think in general one
theme of my book of my work is there are
no magic pills
and and i don't think that's something
to be
um
upset about i think it is doing us as a
species a disservice to think
that
these complex minds that we possess can
all be just turn on or off if you will
with respect to chatter by doing one
thing or another it's a lot more
complicated than that and i think you
know self affirmations can help along
with other tools what situation is
positive affirmations useful for
um
that's a good question um
if it's a temporary kind of stressor
that you're experiencing something that
is not going to be a recurrent source of
distress
somewhere where you need a little bit of
ego in inflation that would be a good a
good instance to try that out
rose nominees who is was the ufc
strawweight females champion up until
saturday when she had the most boring
fight in the history of the ufc uh she
walks out to the
um octagon saying i'm the best i'm the
best i'm the best she says that over and
over and sadly that absolutely didn't
come through in her performance uh on
saturday but that i was interested by
would it be better if she was saying
rose is the best um that would have been
an interesting
an interesting question well i mean i i
definitely i will say every before i do
any
um
you know big big high stakes
presentation it's
you've got this man you've got this it's
third person it's it's me channeling my
high school wrestling coach and what he
would say to me before a big match dope
i love that so there's
a ton of different strategies that
you've got we've gone through some of
the distancing ones what are in your
opinion the highest impact strategies
that people can do that we haven't gone
through so far that we haven't gone
through um
rituals those are those are a really
useful one so many people report
engaging in rituals which are these
rigid sequences of behaviors that are
infused with meaning
when they're stressed out
or in high performance context and
there's research showing that they can
be very beneficial they provide people
with
a sense of order and control which is
often lacking when we're experiencing
chatter they're often
potentially demanding so they draw our
attention away
from our chatter
um so try a ritual it can be something
your culture gives you or something you
make up yourself you just don't want to
become too beholden to the ritual where
a ritual can get
out of hand is rolls into superstition
doesn't it
well yeah you know and a little bit of
superstition's okay also a little bit
but when it becomes something that
you can't that that interferes with with
your ability to like live a
quote-unquote relatively normal life in
the sense that if you don't do this you
need to stop and go back to do it
because things then it's becoming more
problematic
um so rituals are another good one
creating order around you uh operates by
a similar principle i tend not to be
very organized um
in my home you wouldn't know it from the
background but typically if you if i
turn my computer to the side you would
see mountains
of papers and books
and um but when i have chatter
this place is just in tip top perfect
shape same principle here when you're
experiencing chatter you feel like
things are out of control they're not
ordered in your mind your thoughts are
racing pinballing back and forth you can
compensate
for the lack of order you feel in your
mind by creating order around you and so
that's another tool very easy is that
compensatory control is that what that
is yes that's compensate compensatory
control
it's uh it's one way that uh rituals as
well as organizing uh can help people
um
uh nature exposure to green spaces um
lots of compelling data showing that
that can have restorative effects so we
know chatter consumes our attention try
reading a book when you're worried about
something good luck right you read the
page the words but you don't remember
anything you've read
it's because the chatter is consuming
your attention
turns out
nature green spaces uh are like an
energizer battery for your attention
they help restore it and the way this
works is
when you go for a walk in a green space
you're surrounded by
well i should say a safe green space not
a place where
um either people or animals are going to
come and get you but if you go for a
walk in a nice park or a tree-lined
street you're surrounded by really
interesting pleasant looking things that
gently
draw your attention
the trees and the shrubs and you're not
really carefully
studying the geometrical structure of
the
leaves maybe you are one second mate uh
can you come back in about one hour
please
one hour uno
hour classes
just wait yeah no no no no if you
[Music]
one hour
see that that is repurposing you
through me through the headphones
into guatemala cheers mate what were you
saying we're in nature
can can help restore our attention and
the way it works is
uh
when you're in nature you're surrounded
by interesting things that that gently
draw your attention
away
and uh
so funny
for the people that are just listening
the um the lady that's come to try and
clean my um hotel room has decided that
not only did i want her in one hour to
come back and do the room but i also
wanted one agua una agua so she's just
delivered me a bottle of water right to
the desk
hey you asked for it man oh yeah but i
didn't mean to
bloody hell okay yeah nature um another
here's something that i learned about
actually the other day um
i
i read that
looking at the sky through a tree
through tree branches
there's some um restorative effect for
our brain because of the the
criss-crossing pattern of the branches
that typically in nature we wouldn't see
straight lines you know like the edges
of buildings and stuff like that
so this is some fascinating work this is
that no bro i haven't pulled that out of
my ass is that is that legit no there's
actually there's actually work that's
yes i knew it that um so
some of this work actually
has really tried to drill down into the
ingredients that explain how
nature helps us and
looking at does it have to do with the
irregular there are a few straight lines
in nature so there are curved edges and
ragged you know jagged edges and all
that kind of gently draws our attention
towards it in ways that that can be
helpful so no very very good fine you're
reading widely uh interestingly enough
it's not just
these
the way that nature helps us isn't
restricted to the visual modality
there's also work showing that natural
sounds like hearing the chirping
and the you know the leaves crinkling in
the fall all of that also has that
restorative um benefit as well so what
do you mean when you say restorative
restorative so attention is limited we
only have so much of it and oftentimes
we need our attention in order to manage
or chatter right we've got to think like
think differently about what we're going
through reroute the the dialogue well if
we have no attention
it could be hard with no energy if you
will mental energy to engage in those
cognitive exercises
it's it's it's really challenging i mean
that's one of the reasons why it's so
hard to deal with chatter in the middle
of the night
because your brain or parts of your
brain are effectively
asleep being recharged right so you
don't have access to those attentional
resources that you would during the day
so if chatter is wiping out your
attention
then it stands to reason that if you
could get some replenishment
that should help you and that's what the
nature work shows
what are some of the triggers that you
use or that you advise
so that people can become aware when
they've been lost in chatter
this to me seems like sort of the first
mover it's like the first step in this
yeah
step one is um knowing what chatter is
having a vocabulary for understanding
what's happening to you i think is
incredibly important rumination is
chatter about the past worries chatter
about the future but fundamentally if
you find yourself in a thought loop
trying to work through some kind of
problem but not making any progress
that's an indicator that you're
experiencing it step two is to recognize
that there's actually things you can do
to manage that chatter
i i find it remarkable how many people
think don't realize that they have
agency in this situation that there are
actually things they can do there's just
one study
looked at um
teens and ask teens how much um
you know are you able to control your
emotions essentially
40 thought that they couldn't
40
so what happens if you don't think you
can control something you're not going
to take any steps to actually try to do
it so having the expectation
that you can in fact manage your chatter
i think is enormously important that's
step two
step three is familiarizing yourself
with the tools um there are lots of them
and um
you got to know what they are
if if you know to give them a shot it's
like if you want to train your physique
you got to know
what are the exercises that you use to
get in shape right
you just stare at the machines all you
want if you don't know how to use them
nothing is going to happen
and then the final step is to start
doing some experimenting with the tools
what science has done a really good job
of doing is
identifying the tools profiling how they
work in a very careful fine-grained way
what we have not yet done we're starting
to do it now we it's going to be a while
we haven't figured out how to prescribe
sets of tools to different people like
chris you come to me with a problem the
sock dilemma could be the chapter of my
next book the opening story
i don't know how to give you s like i
can't give you six tools to deal with
the sock fiasco and then give my buddy
fred three different ones for the you
know
flower episode that they're dealing with
right we don't have that level of
understanding of how different tools
interact
for different people in different
situations so while we're waiting to do
that science the invitation i like to
give everyone is to start
self-experimenting on your own i've
identified like four to six tools they
work really well for me like the moment
i detect the chatter brewing i implement
those tools usually it nips it in the
bud but those those sets of tools that
work well for me they're different from
the ones my wife uses she uses three or
four other ones and that's okay so start
that self-experimentation process
how can people deal with the frustration
when someone falls prey to
chatter that they think that they've
supposedly been working on and trying to
improve there's this sort of second
order self-referential
you were supposed to be past this you
shouldn't be at the mercy of this blah
blah blah
well um
that's a good question um what i would
suggest is is remind yourself that
you're not alone i think normalizing
these experiences can often be really
powerful
and what's what's been really astounding
to me over the past couple of years
having a chance to talk about this work
with lots of people who have achieved
some level of success is
the remarkable frequency with which they
all struggle with these kinds of
experiences at times in their lives like
i have yet to meet someone who doesn't
struggle with chatter
to some degree in their lives i think
it's part of being human
and so if your chatter happens to deal
with the same thing that you thought
you've
conquered before
so what you know give it another go and
uh and and you know try to get it under
control i think beating ourselves up
excessively about things
doesn't do much good being a little
critical with ourselves for short
periods of time when we screw up that
can be useful but beyond that initial
hey you messed up now let's figure out
how to do better beyond that you don't
want to get stuck there
ethan cross ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do why should they find
you online
www.ethancrosswiththekross.com is the
best way to find me and i'm on social
media instagram
twitter and linkedin as well dude i
really appreciate your work i think it's
great i think the um
defeating the learned helplessness that
people have inside of their own minds is
is a really important piece of work and
i'm super excited to see what you come
up with over the next few years
thanks so much for having me really fun
stimulating conversation and looking
forward to having some more down the
road what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
subscribe peace